الطفله شامه في احد مشافي مدينه ادلب في
تخضع لي العنايه المركزه وتحديدا في مشفى
الشفاء ضمن المدينه طبعا الطفله مهدده
ببتر اها نتيجه سقوط سقف منزلها عليها
وبقائها تحت الانقاض مده طويله تجاوزت
الاربعين ساعه طبعا تعاني ايضا الطفله شام
من من بعض
يعني الامراض
والاعراض في القلب والكلى وجسدها يعني
الطفل الى حد هذه اللحظه في العنايه
المركزه يشرف عليها العديد من الاطباء ضمن
كوادر مشفى الشفاء كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل
ضمن المدينه طبعا
الشام هي من مدينه ارمناز غرب ادلب يعني
اصيبت نتيجه انهيار منزلها في الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه هذا الانهيار ادى
لمقتل امها وشقيق
وشقيقتها في حين نشت هي وابيها واثنين من
اشقائها
طيب محمد هل هي غائبه عن الوعي هل سيواصل
الاطباء علاجها في ادلب ان هناك فرص او
محاولات لعلاجها في او نقلها الى مكان اخر
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الطفل الان في
العنايه المركزه هي هي اغلب الاوقات تكون
غائبه عن الوعي وفي بعض الاحيان تستيقظ
طبعا جميع المحاولات الان هي لمعالجتها في
ادلب نظرا لان الحدود مغلقه لا توجد
امكانيه لنقلها الى خارج الحدود السوريه
مثلا نقلها لتركيا لان جميع المعابر مغلقه
امام الحالات الطبيه ولكن يسعى الجميع هنا
لانقاذ الطفله شام كما يحاول الجميع
لانقاذ المئات من الاطفال التي الذين في
حالاتهم تشابه حاله الطفله شام في في عموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا